okay talking about communicating ideas
to other scientists i recall you saying
that when you were in your younger years
you would
speak about ideas and then they would
get rebuffed but then someone who's on
the periphery listening in would then
advance those ideas and maybe they would
be advanced to the level of becoming new
fields in physics or insights or
or inventions and so on
can you give me some examples of that
yeah it happened several times and you
know early on in my career i i looked
for um
affirmation for
other people um to accept
an idea that i proposed before i would
advocate for it and
uh very often i was disappointed because
i'll give you an example um 21 years ago
i
thought that
you know it would be interesting to to
see if there is a correlation between
the mass of black holes at the centers
of galaxies
and the
the depth
of the gravitational potential well that
they're embedded in so in other words if
black holes grow
they behave like kids you know they
eat as much food as they can uh from the
table until they become too energetic
and then they throw off the food from
the table and
so if that's the case then
black holes would grow up to a certain
mass
at which point they release so much
energy they become so energetic that
they clean off
the food that allows them to continue to
grow and um so i suggested let's check
if the black hole masses are correlated
with
the depth of the gravitational potential
well of the galaxy that hosts them and
the way to measure that is by the speed
by which stars are moving within that
galaxy near the core of the galaxy and
when i suggested that people said no
that's not interesting it's it's
probably there is nothing interesting in
that relation and i remember mentioning
it at the conference and it was
completely rebuffed and then we had a
junior faculty search at the astronomy
department and as it happens in the
short list there were two people working
exactly on
on the central black holes in galaxies
and i suggested to both of them
independently to check that and
uh since they were young people they
decided to do that and they had all the
data in principle i could have done it
as well anyway they did it and each of
them got so excited a few months later
they said wow there is a very tight
correlation between the black hole mass
and the characteristic speed of stars in
in the galaxy that hosts it
and
then they decided to publish and they
published exactly the same time the two
teams and then they started fighting
with each other for the credit because
it became the hot the hottest thing in
the field
and then
for for a decade it became the thing
that everyone talks about and that was
the first indication and then a couple
of years later i
uh suggested that to call i had a
sabbatical
at princeton and i suggested to a few
people that were experts in the
black holes and and the info of gas onto
black holes i suggested uh perhaps we
should calculate what happens when there
is a hot spot a region that is very
bright orbiting a black hole very
closely
so that you can perhaps map the space
and time around the black hole this way
and they completely dismissed it and
said well there would never be a hotspot
that maintains its integrity that
this is not worth doing
uh and so i came back to to harvard
after the sabbatical and i suggested it
to a postdoc of mine and we did the
calculation we wrote a few papers
and then uh
just a year and a half ago two years ago
a group in germany uh discovered exactly
that phenomena they
found a hot spot moving around the black
hole at the center of the milky way
galaxy just in the way that we that i
envisioned and
they it was the hotspot was orbiting
very close to the black hole and so once
again
and then
i can give you many more examples you
know i gave for example a lecture on
gravitational wave astrophysics which is
a new way of
doing astrophysics
astrophysics traditionally astronomy was
based on light collecting light but then
according to einstein's theory of
gravity when you have massive objects
like black holes that are very compact
they distort space and time around them
and when they move close to each other
they can send out waves and these are
called gravitational waves and at the
time it was 2013 i thought it's an
important subject for
the coming years and i decided to give a
lecture about it in a winter school for
students and then 10 minutes into my
talk one of the other lecturers
who who was by the way still is 20 years
younger than me so it has nothing to do
with age
but he's very conservative he's
how long ago was this
this was 2013 january
and
he stood up and
said
why are you wasting the time of these
graduate students on a subject that will
clearly not be important during their
lifetime
for their careers
uh and just two years later that's
allowed in front of everyone in front of
it yeah that's on video you can we can
find it
uh and you know he was
much younger than i am
working on
uh star formation and so forth a
conservative
astronomer so to speak uh but young
relatively young and so
two years later the ligo collaboration
announced or discovered uh the
announcement came uh six months later
but then
you know in uh
in august uh 2015 it was discovered that
there was an event a gravitational wave
event discovered by lago and that
ushered a new era in astrophysics where
gravitational waves are being used to
discover
objects that otherwise do not emit any
light black holes that come together
and the the nobel prize was awarded for
that a few years ago
uh and uh clearly you know these the
same students that were in the audience
were still doing their phds where this
discovery was made and so saying
why are you wasting the time of these
students on a subject that would never
be important was clearly invalid
uh and
you know it happened to me many times
and at some point like five years ago i
said to myself the hell with it i i
don't need confirmation from other
people you know it's just
well it makes you know it makes me
depressed that to to listen to the
criticism and then realize
that the this is the the you know the
hottest thing in in the field later on a
few years later so
how is that possible well it is possible
because uh
people are not they do not have the
vision about the future and they are
very they they prefer to dismiss a new
you know you know new ideas innovation
and so forth just
because it takes them out of their
comfort zone they're used to doing
business as usual and
and so five years ago as or so i decided
to basically not listen and just do what
i think is right based on
my inner compass
and you can see that that nowadays you
know um as a young
scientist i would never be able to
sustain the pressure the the
social pressure that exists around me
right now but
i'm sort of immune to it by now